the math when you lay out a plan even
though you've absolutely done nothing
yet you just laid out a plan that's all
you did you just recognized it is doable
yes but you've actually done nothing
your stress goes way down you know when
we know from psychology research that
when we focus on something intently we
begin to see it everywhere the example
that they've given research studies is
when you go buy a car last time you
bought a car live studio audience you
can play along with me here you remember
commenting on how you saw that blue
minivan or whatever you bought
everywhere over the next week even your
kids were like hey there's our car well
the god of cars didn't just drop them in
on the road it's that you focus so
intently on a purchase like this that we
begin to see it and as you described
when we begin to see that I can pay it
off in four months six months 10 months
here's what happens you begin to truly
see the opportunities because all of a
sudden you go wait a second I can do
this and the power of belief is
Unstoppable